I think an important thing in any learning
strategy or any learning method that
we use is to do what we want to do.
Hi there, Steve Kaufmann here,
uh, today I want to talk about
my strategy for learning Arabic.
And remember if you enjoy my
videos, please subscribe, click
on the bell for notifications.
And if you follow me, follow me on a
podcast service, please leave a review.
So Arabic, Arabic spoken by, I don't
know, 350-400 million people in the world.
An area of the world
that's often in the news.
Well, I was very motivated to
learn Arabic, but I've been at
it for quite a while and I'm
probably not doing that well.
And so I want to go over my strategy
and things that, uh, maybe have changed
in my strategy and maybe my experience
can be helpful to other people.
Uh, I will show you in my statistics
at LingQ when I started with
Arabic, uh, I will show you that
I started Arabic in April of 2018.
That not long thereafter I also started
learning Persian and not long after
that I started learning Turkish.
So I had this strategy of learning three
major languages of the Middle East.
Uh, my motivation was...
I started with Hebrew cause
my wife and I were visiting...
in fact, I did Greek and Hebrew cause
we were going to visit Crete and Israel.
Then I went to Jordan and I said,
there's a lot more Arabic speakers.
So I went and decided to learn Arabic.
Then I came home and discovered
that in Vancouver, we have so
many Iranian immigrants here.
So I decided to learn
Persian at the same time.
Uh, and then my wife was watching this
Turkish mini-series on Netflix so I
said, why don't I go after these three
major languages of the Middle East?
Um, I dropped Turkish, uh, because
written in the Latin alphabet,
it's in fact easier for me.
A major obstacle in my Arabic
learning is the writing system.
It's simply so difficult for the brain to
get used to a different writing system.
So I decided to focus on
Persian and Arabic, both of
which use the Arabic script.
Then the other problem, of course,
with Arabic there is standard Arabic,
which nobody speaks as a native
language, but which is the language
used in, you know, education in, in
political discussions, on, you know,
television, podcasts and so forth.
Uh, most things are written in Standard
Arabic, but if you go to Lebanon or
Syria or Egypt, not to mention Morocco
or Iraq or the Persian Gulf uh,
people speak various forms of Arabic.
And so I initially had the strategy of
focusing my Arabic, uh, effort on Standard
Arabic, but then more recently I decided
because the movies are all from Lebanon
or from Egypt or sometimes from the Gulf.
Uh, and of course that's the
language that people speak that
is the conversational language.
So I said, I should try
to learn those as well.
So I had a tutor in, uh, Egyptian
Arabic, in fact, yeah one, and we  have
at LingQ, we have a number of resources
in both Levantine and Egyptian Arabic.
Uh, but what I found after a while is that
by trying to speak Egyptian Arabic with
my Egyptian Arabic tutor, in the end, I
ended up not being able to speak anything.
Uh, and so I had this experience
the other day, and this is what sort
of triggered my decision to change
my strategy, which I'm coming to.
Um, so I was actually cleaning
my deck because my deck, I have a
big wooden deck and get a lot of,
uh, you know, moss growing on it.
So I actually bought a power
washer and a great power washer.
It took me quite a while to
assemble it, but it works.
Uh, and in the middle of doing that,
I said, I'm going to go down...
I wasn't confident the power
washer would do the job.
I'm going to buy some vinegar
and I'm going to scrub the
deck as well with vinegar.
And then I said, I'll drop by...
there's an area where there's
like three Persian, uh, stores.
One is a guy who fixes electronic
equipment and then there's a little
place where they sell kebabs and then
there's a coffee shop and there's a
little patio in between the three of them.
So I go there.
So I walk into the coffee shop and I, and
it's got the same name as the kebab shop.
And I said, are you connected?
Yes.
So I can eat here?
And then I said, Salaam expecting to
speak Persian, but she was from Lebanon.
So we spoke Arabic and I couldn't
say anything in Levantine Arabic.
Basically what came out
was my Standard Arabic.
And she was very happy with my Arabic.
She told other people, of course,
they're always very nice to you about
how well I speak Arabic, which isn't
true, of course, but I was surprised
at how much I could say in Standard
Arabic, even though I had left it and
was trying to learn Egyptian Arabic.
Just as a matter of interest, uh, people
who walked into that, oh, and this lady
who was originally from Lebanon had lived
in China, but she didn't speak Chinese.
She'd lived in Sweden.
So we spok in Swedish and she had some
connection with Russian, which I don't
know, but she spoke Russian and lo and
behold, some Persian people came in and
we spoke Persian and then another person
came in from Moldova and we spoke Russian.
So I had a whole...
oh.
And there was another gentleman
sitting there who had lived in
Korea and wanted to learn languages.
And I persuaded him to join LingQ.
I had a great time, but I walked away
from that saying the language, the Arabic
language that I spent the most time with,
the Arabic language that I can actually
say something in is Standard Arabic.
I now know enough of Egyptian Arabic
and Levantine Arabic that some of
the things you know, that they do...
so it's, you know ... uh, you know, the
Levantine's say ... at the end of the
sentence instead of ... at the beginning
to introduce a question, uh, you know
... or all these things in Egyptian, uh, or in
Levantine, I know enough of them now that
I can understand better if someone is kind
of speaking mostly ... but mixing in a lot
of dialect or a lot of regional variation.
So I've kind of achieved what I hope
to achieve, but I'm going to go back
to speaking Standard Arabic mixing in a
bit of Egyptian or Levantine, depending
on the situation, hoping to understand.
And very often we pick
up from other people.
So if I'm speaking to someone and I'm
sort of mixing in, it's a bit like
my ... if I mix in a bit of Egyptian
or Levantine but stick to what I know.
I think that's going to
enable me to communicate.
So my strategy where I've said,
initially, I said, you know, stay
with ... because I can listen to podcasts.
Then I said, no, I'm going to learn,
you know, Egyptian or Levantine and
put some effort into both of those.
And now I'm saying those are good for
comprehension and I'll mix some of
those expressions in, but basically
I'm going to stay with, um, Standard.
So I think an important thing in any
learning strategy or any learning method
that we use is to do what we want to do.
The only thing that really matters in
language learning is the attitude of
the learner and the time we put in.
So some people like flashcards,
some people like Anki, some
people like a Duolingo.
It doesn't matter.
As long as you enjoy what you're doing,
you will improve as long as you're
putting in the time, you'll do fine.
So on that basis and, and we can change.
I can think that my...
I should be doing this in Arabic.
And then I changed my mind.
The other thing I would do now
is I would not attempt three
languages at the same time.
Uh, because it means you're going to
be slowed down in each one of them.
On the other hand, I
have a sense of Persian.
I can actually converse in person.
I can kind of converse in Arabic
and I have a bit of a sense of what
Turkish is all about and whatever I
put into those languages it's not lost.
Cause if I go back to my Turkish, which
is the, now the weakest of the three,
very quickly will I get back to where
I was, and then I can take it forward.
So it's not a, I didn't make a mistake
by sort of dissipating my energies.
It just meant that I didn't get as far
in any one of them as I would have been
able to do had I focused on just one.
So, and I'm going to leave you with
a little walkthrough of my statistics
at LingQ so that you'll see, you know,
what the history has been of my, uh,
learning, uh, of those of those languages.
And after that, uh, I will leave a
couple of videos that you can go to,
uh, to see, you know, my Arabic, uh,
three years ago, and then two years ago,
already, four years ago and two years ago.
Okay.
Thank you for listening.
Bye for now.
I thought I'd have a look at
what I've been doing in Arabic.
This is my Arabic page at LingQ,
as it looks right now, I've
kind of been bouncing around.
I've been importing some articles.
I've been looking at
my Jordanian cartoons.
I watched a bit of this Egyptian movie.
Then I go back to my
mini-stories in Standard Arabic.
I've also done my mini-stories in
Egyptian Arabic, a little bit in...
it doesn't show here, but
in Levantine Arabic as well.
And, uh, I'm kind of a bit at loose
ends here as I've explained in my video,
but let's just look at my history.
So I think, you know that if you click
on your, or you can even, you know,
do it this way, hit the down arrow,
you've got to get to your profile and
you can see what your history has been.
So you can see that I haven't been that
active this, these past seven days.
However, if I go to my all time
statistics, I can see that I
started poking around at Arabic,
uh, around the end of 2017.
If I look at known words, if I look
at known words, if I look at LingQs
created, I actually started, I guess,
you know, poking around in 2017, but
really my major effort was early in
2018, that was a major spurt in Arabic.
Um, and I've gone through phases, as I
said, between my major initial effort,
effort in ... and more recently trying
to get a, a, a bit of an exposure to,
uh, Levantine and Egyptian Arabic.
Now you'll see this date, 2018.
2018 April.
If I look at my situation in, first of
all, I see the first Semitic language I
started with was Hebrew, uh, because I
was going to, to Israel and I put some
effort into Hebrew, but when my wife and
I ended up going to Jordan and I realized
that actually there's a lot more Arabic
speakers than I dropped Hebrew entirely.
I may go back.
But, uh, so I started into my, uh,
Arabic, and then I came back to
Vancouver and lo and behold, there's
far more Persian speakers here.
So again here by about, you know, the, I
guess the beginning of 2019, I was putting
more effort into Persian than into Arabic.
And so I've kind of kept my Persian
activities going alongside my Arabic.
If I go back to where my Arabic was
you'll see that I've kind of kept
them both going, going simultaneously.
The other thing that I did was I decided
to, you know, I'm interested in the
Middle East and my wife is watching
series on Netflix in Turkey, Turkish.
So by the middle of 2019, I put a three
month stint into learning Turkish.
So a lot of distractions
from my Arabic learning.
Uh, so I just wanted to show you that
as a sort of, um, some background to,
uh, what I, uh, was talking about in
my, uh, video on my Arabic learning
strategy and, and, uh, you know, I
will leave you with two videos that
you can watch to see how well I did
at two different stages in my Arabic.